foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing Fantastic Beasts for with
secrets of Dumbledore's release half a
year ago Harry Potter fans have been
left with a distinct craving for more
but today I'm going to exploring if and
when that's even a possibility now let
me just start off by saying that we
waited a long time for the last film in
fact four years separated the third
installment The Seekers of Dumbledore
from the second the crimes of
Grindelwald and six years separated the
latest release from the first Fantastic
Beasts and Where to Find Them with the
six-year timeline for just three films
things have certainly been slow going
especially if we consider that these
films are furthering one of the most
beloved film franchises of all time and
I think the question we need to be
asking now is where does that leave us
we're now six months post secrets of
Dumbledore which means just enough time
has passed that we should be able to
start piecing together Whispers the
fourth installment right sadly that
doesn't seem to be the case in fact
Eddie Redmayne in a recent interview
with Indie wire was asked about both his
reprisal of Newt scamander as well as
what may be next for Fantastic Beasts
when pressed on whether or not he had
any information about the fourth
installment he said I don't it's more
question for JK Rowling and David Yates
and Warners but I don't know I'm afraid
I can't add to that he did add however
that he's always up for getting back
into character as magic zoologist newt's
Commander I love playing nude he's a
sweet man he added though the Fantastic
Beasts storyline was originally slated
for five films in total things are not
looking so good why well despite the
gradual Improvement of the films at
least in my eyes the box office is
certainly no reflection of that the
secrets of Dumbledore grossed 400
million worldwide down 39 from its
precursor the crimes of Grindelwald at
659 million which in turn was down 19
from Fantastic peace and where to find
them while 400 million is nothing to
scoff at it's the lower and lower
amounts that are caused by a concern
these figures aren't exactly promising
and if the financial worries weren't
enough we've also got to consider all of
the controversies surrounding the
franchise Ezra Miller who plays Credence
has been arrested multiple times over
the last few years Johnny Depp was
replaced and rolling is certainly no
stranger to controversy it also appears
that many of the actors filmmakers
involved are putting their energy into
other projects to name a few red Mains
working on the good nurse Jude laws
working on a handful of projects and
David Yates is directing a conspiracy
drama film for Netflix those who aren't
shrouded in controversy seem to have
their hands full so what does that mean
for the story is it over well while
there's still very much to explore in
the time period before Harry Potter
things were left on an ending note sort
of grindelwald's plans to achieve power
were thwarted a new Dumbledore is
revealed and everything feels more or
less copacetic do I hope that things
will continue absolutely but as of right
now things aren't looking so good
however if I were to look at the future
of Fantastic Beasts through an
unwavering veil of positivity there are
a few things that make things feel a
little more hopeful first of all
credence's character is dying which
makes continuing on without him fairly
straightforward secondly six months may
just simply not be enough time to begin
having a discussion about another film
perhaps Warner Bros are simply waiting
for actors producers and directors to
tie off Loose Ends before they get going
again lastly we still have yet to see
some of the most anticipated aspects of
the story one of the most compelling
aspects of Harry Potter law is the fated
duel between Dumbledore and Grindelwald
that finally gets him locked away in
nurmangard are they going to deprive us
of this what do you guys think will
Fantastic Beasts 4 move forward or is
that it for the Fantastic Beasts
franchise leave a comment down below
with what you think until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live